[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are very few people in the united
states
who have ascended the great heights not
just of presidential politics but also
of reality tv
i can name two people who have done it
one of them
president donald trump the other one my
friend sean spicer who is the author of
the new book leading america president
trump's commitment to people
patriotism and capitalism sean thank you
for coming on
thank you michael i appreciate that
dubious distinction absolutely you know
it's amazing i'm trying to pick out
which reality show i could go on i don't
i don't know if i
i wanted to ask sarah that the other day
i'd had her on my show and i was
thinking the one question i didn't ask
her is okay what show were you going on
and then i saw
trump you know he was he was very
concerned about me going on dancing with
the stars
and then i saw him pull that ymca thing
off and i was like you know
well he's trying out that's the thing i
think he's preparing he says in another
four years
right after i leave the white house this
is my next gig as i'm going to be doing
right village people dance moves on
stage
so sean you have written before you are
a new york times best-selling author
however this is an election book i mean
this is a book
making a case about the 2020 election
you start the book and you say every
year we hear
this is the most important election in
our lifetimes blah blah blah
you say this one really may be and and i
tend to agree i think certainly within
my lifetime this is by far the most
important election
i don't think there's anything odd by
the way that
each successive election would be the
most important in our lifetime
if the stakes of our politics are
getting more and more urgent
so what do you see at play here in 2020
should the president lose or should the
president get another four years
yeah and i don't think i would have said
this if we were running against 10 year
old
ago joe biden but we're running against
the
harris biden administration um and that
concerns me because i think the
difference now is that
biden recognizes that he wants to be
president for two reasons one to be able
to say that he stopped donald trump
and the second is he wants to be able to
have uh
this be the most progressive president
in history and so that he has abandoned
his principles
just to be able to say hey look if i can
go down as the person that shows the
first african-american
or first black uh female vice
presidential candidate and i can pass
all this
far left progressive policy that will
cement me as this
icon to the progressive left then it's
worth it and so i i think that
you look at alexandria ocasio-cortez and
bernie sanders
and all of the stuff that they claim
that they've been doing with biden
look michael the deal is if biden were
to win there's no scenario politically
where i can see him winning and not
taking a democratic senate and that
means it'll have a democratic senate
democratic house
for a minimum of two years and that
means for two years
it's katie bar the door baby because
every crazy left-wing policy is coming
through
and so that's number one number two is
in the book i
outline what's going on in big tech in
corporate america
in hollywood in journalism in academia
and
let people understand that it's not just
the one-off thing you hear the last 96
hours have proved
point-blank the media will do everything
to cover up stories
to fit the agenda that they want the
outcome that they want and big tech will
follow and make sure that they get what
they want done
what's happening right now is a
mere symbol of the magnitude of what's
to come
if this election goes from the other
direction we just saw last week
the oldest continuously published daily
newspaper in the country which was
founded by alexander hamilton
was barred from twitter and from
facebook
and it's and it remains barred they
suppressed the link to that damaging
story about hunter and joe biden
but the new york post is still not
allowed on twitter
how on earth in in a representative
self-government
do we allow our public square to be
taken over
by a handful of highly partisan tech
oligarchs
so there's two chapters in the book one
on journalism schools that show you that
anything that's not in advance of a far
left agenda gets blocked and
it once you read the chapter on
journalism schools you get it you walk
away and you go aha
it makes sense now number two when you
read the story on big tech
you get that as well but the end of the
day what blows my mind is that for the
last three years we've heard about the
integrity of the press and the freedom
of the press
and not suppressing the ability of the
of the first amendment
and you're now watching big media
protect
uh its own interests and big tech
backing it up it's it's
i'm actually blown away the extent to
which no one
in the media is fighting for this and
saying wow
we've got to preserve the first
amendment we've got to preserve the
freedom of the press
yeah they're complicit they are truly
tilting the scales of this election and
are complicit you know one thing i
really like about the book that you
touch on
is it it sort of is like a voter guide
in the sense that
it hits every big issue it just kind of
puts every big issue from tech
to the mainstream media to the political
establishment to
the hollywood all these things into
perspective and what they
what they mean right now what they'll
mean going into the future but speaking
of hollywood you you do
touch on dancing with the stars and
reality tv
and i think you know obviously you've
got a great personal experience of this
but that relationship between reality tv
and hollywood
and politics is an important one it
always has been but maybe now more than
ever
well yeah and and i go through and
detail my experience and just with the
stars
but then i also talk about like for
example late night television when i
grew up
it was carson and leno and letterman um
and and now we have and they were they
were left-leaning
but they were funny and it wasn't
personal now you have
kimmel myers fallon colbert and their
goal
is to huh samantha bee as well as
another one of them
yeah well more of a gadfly but yeah i
would throw trevor noah into that
category as well
right but the reality is is that they
have made this personal and political
they will
they they are very open about it they're
very clear about it and to the detriment
of ratings and advertisers and resources
they don't care and that's the point in
all this is that hollywood has decided
to
um to abandon any desire of
doing things that are good for an
audience or for
financial purposes to advance a
left-wing agenda that's
vastly different than what's going on
and i lay out in detail the sort of
the the shows and the products and the
projects
that have done very well on the right
and yet they continue to get smothered
because
they don't fit the narrative that
hollywood wants to perpetuate right
and so given that you've got this now
explicitly
vicious openly partisan kind of media
and
and establishment i hate to ask you for
a prediction
but right now we are less than three
weeks away from the election
how do you feel i mean how do you feel
the campaign is going you are nervous
unbelievably nervous i feel good in the
momentum that we're getting like i've
seen all the polls are starting to close
right i think the president's ahead in
ohio he's head in north carolina
he's ahead in florida but by a point or
two it's just
when you see what they're doing this
mail-in voting in nevada and
pennsylvania and other places
truly does concern me and i think that
if the president's not up 125 150 000
votes in pennsylvania on election night
he loses
it's just i'm sorry they've done
everything they can to rewrite election
rules in the last couple of months
um and i think they know it so i'm very
nervous
i i always am nervous around election
time um
you know i i just because that's how you
have to be
but i i've never seen the democrats go
so fervently
out there and be blatant about how
they're trying to manipulate the the
election law and
what do you say to people in the
mainstream media who insist listen
there's nothing new about mail and
voting
we've had absentee ballots for a long
time no evidence of fraud
nothing to see here you guys are are
making a mountain out of a molehill
well they're lying i mean look absentee
ballads
see what you just did there is what they
do and i know you were doing it
intentionally
is they they sort of say like what do
you say about people who don't like
zucchini
why are oranges okay for you and you're
like whoa you just mixed
two entirely different what and and what
they did is
absentee ballots are fine the
president's talked about that he's voted
by absentee
it requires a voter to ask for and
verify who they are and receive a ballot
mail-in ballot in the case of nevada is
where they literally just send every
single person dead or alive
that's on the bow on their voter rolls a
ballot whether or not they've moved or
not
we know this has not been the case been
before
we know it's had problems in states that
have gone in this direction
and have taken decades to figure it out
why are we doing it
you know fly by night so the reality is
what the media does is sort of does this
sleight of hand where they're like
absentee ballots are not a problem don't
look over here mail in ballots are
i mean and they're trying to confuse
voters and that's the problem that's
happening
is that they use these weasel words and
then say and that's why the president
continues to call it a doubt
no he's called in to doubt the way that
they've changed the rules and sort of
made mail-in ballots universal and again
we know this for a fact that people move
we know it for a fact that people died
those are both true
and yet they've done nothing to clean up
the voter rolls and where are the
ballots that then just randomly go to
these people
and you you see these incidents by the
way of ballots being found on the side
of the road or ballots being found in
the wrong room
but i just i i love it to your point
when the media come out and say
listen there there is no evidence that
there's ever been a problem
with widespread mail and voting and you
say well wait a second we've never had
widespread male in voting
where could the evidence even be exactly
that's the point is that it's like
it's it's it's like they this is
completely new and then they say well we
don't have any evidence and it's like
but there's also an element of common
sense right so that's like saying that
well my house has never been broken into
right so there's no evidence that i need
a lock
well i mean my point is is that you
protect what you
value and and treat as sacred right so
i lock my doors because of what i i want
to protect my family and my belongings i
don't
lock my doors because i've been broken
into eight times and i'm trying to
prevent it again
and i think the question is why wouldn't
we protect something so sacred as our
voting
right i i see a little bit of a parallel
to chesterton's fence which is you have
left wingers saying
i see no reason for there to be election
day i see no reason for there not to be
widespread mail in voting and you say
well okay how about you
come up with the reason as to why we've
protected these institutions for so many
years
then if you want to reform it you can
come out but but of course
i think one of the problems that i took
and i understand i'm a fan of absentee
ballots
because i think people travel and work
and i mean i mean i i have a show
uh that i i have to do some stuff for
here and there and it makes it difficult
but there's a difference between that
and allowing people to start to vote in
september think about all the things
that have happened
between the first couple weeks in
september and now um and so
we've got to be very careful how we do
this that we don't
short sell the voter because the issue
is things happen you go well
sorry you voted in september there was a
debate in between then the president got
coronavirus in between
we found this hard drive with hunter
biden stuff on in between then i mean
all this stuff happens but because the
media encouraged people to do it early
they didn't allow them to see a lot of
the stuff unfold
right that's right and i mean even what
we've seen in the past week we've had
town halls we've got more debates even
though people have already voted you
know one one thing i think that's very
fair and
nice in in the book is you say listen i
don't i try not to paint with a broad
brush
about the fake news media i try to be
specific and point out what my problems
are and who my problems are with
however these days it's getting harder
and harder getting harder
it is because i i just think that
when you i i always liken it like to to
you know when a dog does something wrong
you can't if you don't stop in the
moment and say okay what you just did
then
is bad behavior it's hard a week later
to point it out but at the same time
you're right is it over and over again
this issue with hunter biden has baffled
me it really has the idea that none of
these
champions of the first amendment of
freedom of the press
are willing to get up and stand up and
say hey wait a second i may not agree
with the sourcing on the new york poster
i'm which i still don't understand what
the issue is i mean i'm like you write a
story about the president's taxes
where it got leaked out but yet you
don't have a problem with
uh a no one in the bible campaign by the
way has said
the emails are not true the pictures are
not true the the computer's not true the
texts are not true
right it's just well guess what steve
bannon found it
i don't care who found it um that's not
an issue here and
if you don't if you look at what's
happening now and don't say wow that is
a massive problem in our media
then i think there's a bigger problem
here well of course i never saw any
issue in big tech or the mainstream
media with
hacked materials or with sourcing when
it came to
melania's phone call that they made a
big to-do about or trump's taxes
or the steele dossier which was
completely cooked up with democrat money
largely
that never was an issue so the double
standard is is pretty outrageous
but as you say right now we've we've got
the momentum perhaps
in in our favor but is there enough time
you know we're we're now
less than three weeks away i mean at a
certain point momentum doesn't matter if
the numbers aren't aren't there
that's right and that's that's why i'm
nervous and i'm concerned but i will say
this
that i think that the trump campaign and
the rnc have the best political
operation and ground game in modern
history
if they can keep this within a political
field goal
i think they can pull it off that's the
key is that the momentum has to be there
towards that end
um i think they can do this um because
remember he had 306 electoral votes last
time he only needs 270 to win
so he actually can shed a state or two
um
but you're right we're not we're we're
too close the upside is this when in
politics you want to peak at the right
moment
if this was a normal year i would be a
little less concerned but the problem is
you have four million votes already cast
in florida
and roughly 28 million or so that have
voted
therefore that concerns me because as
they're peaking
if you peak at the right time but they
shifted the timeline and said oh guess
what we all voted a week ago
right you know theoretically then you
peaked normally at the right time you
just peeked in this cycle too early
that's right
that i actually hadn't thought about it
in those terms but that's what
you know people always say who do you
think is going to win you say well if
you vote if the vote were held today
but of course you know the vote's not
held in july or june but now
the vote is being held depending on
where you live the vote is being held
right now
the stakes stakes never hire i think
that is absolutely true
if you want a very good perspective on
what is at stake in the election
how we got to this place you've got to
check out shawn's book leading america
president trump's commitment to people
patriotism and capitalism and by the way
you can always watch
sean on newsmax at spicer and company
and occasionally you may see me there
as well hopefully this week what a
double bonus that is that's right
uh sean thank you so much we've taken up
enough of your time already but really
encourage people to go out and get the
book
and then i think i will see you over at
your show sometime in the next few days
i believe that's the case thank you
michael i appreciate you having me all
right thanks john
[Music]
[Music]